we're in a culture in which a second of
of lack of productivity is translated
into you know a sense of unworthiness in
the world which is a very pernicious
sensibility that that pervades our
culture I think you know like a couple
years ago I started taking a month off
every year and and those moments of
repose have been profound and not just
helping me make sense of what it is that
I want to do and prioritize projects Etc
but you know kind of below that surface
to really spend some time to think about
like how I want to expend my energies
what my value set is which values
require which energies when Etc and and
learning you know through that process
to say notice when to say no and when to
say yes you know which you know
Downstream
that has like real world you know major
consequences on you know the things that
I do and how I kind of tread the world